when you were coming up as a a mobster
and you know you're you're doing what
you're doing with the family you're part
of
you're buying politicians a lot of times
they'll say well you know it's easier to
buy democrats as politicians so it's
easier to buy republicans but your
experience you said you had an easier
time buying democrats as politicians why
was that easier than buying republicans
they were easier to corrupt i mean it's
it's plain and simple now we didn't say
we're going after democrats they just
happen to be the ones that we were able
to get to
you know we would have got to anybody it
didn't matter and by the way the book is
bipartisan it's not democrats not
republicans right down the middle i name
them both but for some reason you know
it was just easier to to work with
democrats why do you think though
because phil leonetti said when phil and
i spoke and you know we had him in the
in the in the studio and we were
interviewing him
he said the opposite he says look it's
not just the democrats it was also
easier buying republicans you know for
him it was
uh he had as much uh frustration with
republicans as he did with democrats you
know but from your end why was it that
they would come up more from the why
would more democrats come up wanting to
do deals with well you know there's a
couple of them that i know that were
italian to begin with you know remember
i grew up in new york that was our area
there we had 750 made guys guys that
actually took the oath comprised all
five families a lot of us had neighbors
friends relatives that were law
enforcement politicians whatever so a
lot of them were of italian descent and
a couple that i'm i'm not going to
mention the names now but they were
italians
so maybe it was just the jurisdiction
and of course the democrats were majorly
in control in new york so maybe there
were more of them they were easier they
were on the street we had access to them
better but it wasn't like we selected a
democrat it just happened to be that
they were democrats
yeah it uh you know you you sit there
and you think about like when we were
doing mafia states of america
and you know you guys talked about how
gambling used to be illegal now you know
it's it's a full-blown business model
billions of dollars being made
we talked about how you know hard money
lending was illegal now you got these
you know cash places around the corner
everywhere hey come bring your check
thirty two percent thirty three percent
fifty percent they charge more interest
than we did yeah okay literally across
the street you walk by it every single
day
the amp scott it's incred the the the
racketeering there is these merchant
lending accounts whatever they are i
mean they're shylocks that's all they
are
absolute shylocks i mean they charge
more interest than we do than we did
excuse me then we did i don't do that
anymore
i want to be clear on let's clear the
air on that we did
so if you like this clip and you want to
watch another one click right here and
if you want to watch the entire podcast
click right here
[Music]